Speaker 1: So one of the Republican
members on this House select committee
that's investigating the January 6th Trump
riots, Adam Kinzinger, essentially admitted
to Wolf Blitzer last night on CNN that other
than one or two Republican elected officials,
none of them actually believe that Donald Trump
won the 2020 20 election. It's not a surprising
admission, but I would make the point that it's
actually worse that despite not believing it,
they continue mostly to allow the claim to spread
publicly. And we'll get back to that. But before
we look at the video, just as a sort of reminder,
there was a proposed January six commission that
was going to be 9/11 style is the way it was
described. It was proposed months ago. It was
going to be truly bipartisan in the sense that
we would all sort of agree that it's bipartisan,
which meant that there were going to be five
members chosen by the Democrats, five members
chosen by the Republicans. The chairman would be a
Republican, a Democrat, rather, because Democrats
control the House vice chair would be Republican.
Every subpoena would have to be signed off on by
both the Democratic chair and the Republican vice
chair. Republican said no. Whole bunch of reasons
why they said no, many of them bogus. We've talked
about it before. So eventually we get to this
House select committee, which is investigating.
And in this one, House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy said, here's five Republicans reporting
on it. Two of them were Jim Jordan and Jim Banks,
who really should be witnesses or they're
potentially accomplices in the riots.
They have no business investigating them. And so
Nancy Pelosi, the speaker of the House, rightly
said they can't be on the commission ultimately.
We saw Republican Adam Kinzinger and Republican
Liz Cheney placed onto this panel and on after
the first day during which we heard from four
different members of Capitol Police. Last night,
Adam Kinzinger was interviewed by Wolf Blitzer on
CNN. Now, it's really important as we watch this
clip, Adam Kinzinger is talking about elected
officials don't believe Trump really. One, this is
not about Republican voters. That's an important
distinction, which we're going to talk about in
a second. But let's start with the interview here
and very, very important points made.
Speaker 3: We can get the answers. If
any of your Republican colleagues, I'm just
curious, are actually privately said to you,
good work, I support you. Yes. Oh, yeah.
Is that just one or two is it a handful or
give us a give me a ballpark number, you know,
because over time, I don't know. It's there's a
lot of people, you know, and that come up and say
it and it's not any of the ones that go on TV and
spout the big lie and then say it's the ones that
are staying more quiet that I think appreciate the
stand. But it's a lot. And look, Wolf, the thing
to keep in mind, save one or two maybe out here,
nobody. And I think it's very important to repeat,
nobody actually believes the election was stolen
from Donald Trump, but a lot of them are happy to
go out and say it was. Are you still comfortable
being a member of the Republican Party? Have
you given any thought at all maybe of switching
parties as you are you're going to have
to seek reelection next year? Yeah, no,
no. Look, I'm a I'm a Republican at heart, right?
I was a Republican way before Donald Trump since I
was six years old. I believe in the values.
Speaker 1: I'm six year old, by the way.
We could explore that six year old
Republican. But let's not right now.
Speaker 3: I didn't for and I believe that a party
was such a rich history deserves to have people,
even if it's only a couple of us at the
moment in there fighting to restore the soul
of it. So I'm going to fight hard for that.
Speaker 1: So let's let's think about this.
I essentially believe that Adam Kinzinger is
right here. I think there are almost no actual
Republican elected officials who think Trump
won the 2020 election. They're not good people
because privately they don't believe it. They're
actually bad people. I would say. I mean, you
know, it's a simplistic term. But what the
point I'm trying to make is I would respect them
if they came out and said, this is a lie. This
is the Joe Biden one. We might not like it.
I'm not a Democrat, but Joe Biden one. This is
Republicans saying this privately, believing that
Joe Biden won, but not coming out and saying it
and allowing it to be perpetrated and perpetuated
and and blown up in signal boosted by your
colleagues. I would argue that that's actually
even worse. And I know that there are some people
who will hear this and they'll say, I knew that
most of these Republicans had a good head on their
shoulders. I knew it. They couldn't really be so
dumb as to believe that Donald Trump actually won
the election. They're actually they're OK people.
No, no, no, no, no. It's even worse that they are
allowing something like that to be continually
spread, disgust, signal boosted and reported as if
it's news when they don't actually believe it. And
the most infuriating part, and this is where we
have to distinguish between Republican politicians
and. And voters, it is not true that Republican
voters don't believe it. The Republican voters
do believe it. They are pulled on it regularly.
And so these Republican elected officials who
maybe they privately know that Donald Trump
didn't actually win, they are allowing or even
participating in misleading their constituents
because it keeps them politically relevant.
It keeps them on Trump's good side, which they
think maybe they're going to need in twenty two or
in twenty four. If they know it's a lie, then why
are they spreading it or allowing it to spread?
And it's because they know that a lot of the
voters believe it and the voters believing it
probably is beneficial to them in terms of getting
themselves reelected and the the the voters
believing it is having a real impact. You know,
when I drive by this house a few miles away that
has this huge 12 foot wide by, you know, 10 foot
tall Trump flag in the yard that says Trump won,
they really do believe it. And we see the polling
and we see that tens of millions of these people
believe that Donald Trump actually won
so great. There are Republicans who are
immoral or amoral enough that while privately
they know Donald Trump didn't actually win,
they either say publicly that he did or he might
have or they shut their mouths and allow the
Republican Party voters to continue spreading
that idea. They aren't good people because
they privately know the truth. They are bad in the
sense that they don't come out and say, hey, guys,
I might disagree with Democrats on
taxes, abortion, foreign policy,
whatever, but the president of the United States
is Joe Biden because Joe Biden won the election
period fair and square. End of story. And, you
know, I'm not surprised to hear Adam Kinzinger
say it. He's willing to say it. Unfortunately,
many of his colleagues may not believe it,
but they're still willing to allow it to spread
like a virus within the Republican Party.